vous avez dû avoir des annonces qui vous
ont fait plaisir le président de la
république avait voté à évoquer le rsa
qui pourrait être recentré alizés et
d'autres qui vous ont fait moins plaisir
aux impressions monsieur bussereau a
coûté d'accord j'aurais voulu entendre
mon collègue stéphane troussel parce
qu'en général nous pensons sur l'autre
des collectivités territoriales la même
chose brouilla pas grand chose pour les
départements ain dans tout ça soyons
clairs nous oppose en pause depuis
longtemps le principe de du girondin de
la décentralisation d'expérimentation de
la liberté donc ça nous va bien on verra
après quel est le contenu on a le
problème des mineurs étrangers isolés
des mineurs non accompagnés qui n'a pas
été évoquée par le président qui pour
nous un problème de puissants plus grave
et je pense à mon collègue en
seine-saint-denis mais aussi à beaucoup
d'autres départements
et puis sur les allocations
individuelles de solidarité le rsa l'apa
la prestation de compensation du
handicap
bon le présent a ouvert deux pistes la
piste de la recentralisation où la piste
d'inventaire nouveau système de
compensation en disant toute façon à la
fin de l'année j'aiderai les
départements en difficulté et puis il
faut vous est une solution pour le
printemps prochain pour que nous
puissions nous inscrire dans le projet
de loi de finances 2010 9 bon on va
maintenant y travaillent et ont déjà
l'habitude du travail entre nous on
avait commencé un travail pas
inintéressant et du gouvernement manuel
valls on n'a pas été loin d'aboutir
et donc on va travailler dans cette
direction avec l'état dans les délais
qui lui sont impartis c'est-à-dire entre
maintenant et le printemps prochain
ce matin ce matin vous étiez très
critique sur le discours du premier
ministre est ce que vous êtes quand même
un petit peu rassuré après la demande et
à quand vous faites parler à présent la
public après le premier ministre
président dès le premier jeu peut pas
dire grand chose et ce qui était assez
frustrant ce matin c'est pour ça que
j'ai dit que c'était c'était du flou
c'est qu'on a tous posé plein de
questions très précises très technique
les ministres techniques darmanin colons
nous on fait des topos et puis on a
aussi tout s'exprimer les départements
les régions les communes et sénateurs
les députés
et puis in fine est on n'avait aucune
réponse aux prémices nous ça nous a dit
bon voilà c'est un peu énervant mais
vous avez la réponse cet après midi cet
après midi et les réponses était réservé
au président donc nous allons vous eu un
certain nombre
moi je suis content d'un discours
décentralisateur et girondins est encore
plein de choses à régler
et pour les ads nous avons un chemin
nous allons y travailler intelligemment
avec le gouvernement et un désir
d'obtenir d'ailleurs que les présidents
quelle que soit la sensibilité politique
de département puissions nous mettre
d'accord sur une position commune